come back come back well you know the
suit can take the weight right so I take
the tank fly it right up to the generals
Palace drop it at his feet I'm like boom
you looking for this boom are you
looking why do I even talk to you guys
everywhere else that story kills that's
the whole story yes
war machine story was very good then
quality saves so no pepper she's not
coming what about Jane where are the
ladies gentlemen Oh miss Potts has a
company to run so I'm not even sure what
country Jane's in her work and the
convergence is made of the world's
foremost astronomer and the company that
pepper runs is the largest tech
conglomerate on earth it's pretty
exciting there's even talk of Jane
getting a Nobel Prize yeah I think they
must be busy because they'd hate missing
you guys get together but Jane's better
sounds like a hell of a fight sorry I'm
missing if I had known it was gonna be a
firefight I absolutely would have called
I'm not actually sorry I'm just trying
to sound tough very happy chasing cold
leads on our missing persons case
avenging is your world
your world is crazy be it ever so humble
you find a place in Brooklyn yet I don't
think I can afford a place in Brooklyn
well home is home you know
a flight right up to the generals Palace
I drop it at his feet I'm like boom
you're looking for this
I gotta have some no no no no see this
this was aged for a thousand years the
barrels built from the wreck of Broncos
fleet is not meant for mortal men
neither was Omaha Beach blondie stop
trying to scare us
[Music]
you